مقطع فيديو مسرب يطيح بمدير سجنا في
العراق صراخ هستري لمصريه يجبر طائره على
العوده بيليه يعترف في وصيته بسر انكره
طوال حياته هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم
من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
بعد تداول مقطع فيديو مسرب من داخل سجن
بالعراق قرر وزير العدل خالد شواني اعفاء
مدير السجن ومعاونه وعددا من المسؤولين في
هواء حالتهم جميعا الى التحقيق المقطع
الذي اثار ضجه واسعه في مواقع التواصل تم
التقاطه في سجن التاجي قرب بغداد ويظهر
فيه نزلاء الحكومه لانقاذهم من ممارسات
اداره السجناء متهمينها باجبارهم على شراء
المخدرات والهواتف النقاله بمبالغ طائله
فيما طالبه رواد مواقع التواصل بمحاسبه
جميع المتورطين في القضيه
[موسيقى]
في حادثه لقيه تفاعلا واسعا على السوشيال
ميديا ترى قائد طائره متجهه من مطار
القاهره الى مدينه جده لانزال راكبه مصريه
كانت تصرخ بشكل هستري وسائل الاعلام
المحليه كشفت عن حدوث مشاجره عبر الهاتف
بين السيده وزوجها المقيم في السعوديه
بسبب خلافات عائليه مشيره الى ان الزوجه
توعد زوجته بالضرب فور وصولها مطار جده
فيما ترى قائد الطائره التي كانت في
طريقها للاقلاع التره للعوده وانزال سيده
والغاء سفرها بعد ما اصيبت بالانهيار
[موسيقى]
بعد نحوي ثلاثه اسابيع على وفاتها شكلت
وصيه اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه بيليه
مفاجاه لدى الكثيرين بعد ان كشف من خلالها
عن سر انكره طوال حياته صحيفه ماركا
الاسبانيه اوضحت ان بيليه كان ينفي دائما
انه والد ساندرا ارجينا رغم ان اختبار
الحمض النووي من المحكمه اثبت انها بالفعل
ابنته ولكن بعد وفاته وفتح وصيته كانت
المفاجاه اذ ترك بيليه تركته لجميع ابنائه
السبعه بمن فيهم ساندرا التي توفيت منذ 17
عاما دون ان تعرف ان سيعتبرها يوما ما
واحده من ابناءه
عاد الملياردير لهم ماسك ليتصدر حديث ما
وقع التواصل وهذه المره بخبر البدء
بمحاكمه في سان فرانسيسكو لتحديد ما اذا
كان رئيس تسلق قد كتب تغريد احتياليه كما
يتهموه مستثمرون وسائل اعلام افادت بان
القضيه تعود الى عام 2018 عندما غرد ماسك
بانه يريد اخراج شركته تسلم من البورصه
لان له ما يكفي من التمويل للقيام بذلك
الامر الذي تسبب حينها في تارجل سعر سهم
الشركه بشكل حاد لبضعت ايام فيما بدات
المحاكمه باختيار هيئه المحلفين ومن
المتوقع ان تستغرق نحو ثلاثه اسابيح
وفي خبرنا الاخير تتجه انظار عشاق كره
القدم غدا الى ملعب الملك فهد في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض لمتابعه لمواجهه
الاستثنائيه والتاريخيه بين كريستيانو
رونالدو وليونيل ميسي على كاس موسم الرياض
المباراه التي ستكون وديه ستجمع بين نادي
باريس سان جيرمان فرنسي ونجوم فريقي النصر
والهلال السعوديين مع وجود كل من كيليان
مبابي والبرازيلي نيمار في الجانب الفارسي
ايضا فيما سيخوض النجم البرتغاليه اول
مباراه له على الاطلاق من دون انضمامه الى
نادي النصر